you actually got to throw out with Jake
Gyllenhaal you got to throw out the
first pitch yeah which must be been like
that's a great fantasy to get with you
that yeah I was really amazing when we
got to do that well I think we have a
picture here do we have a picture here
yeah there you are with Jake David Ortiz
now I'm told that you did that at that
game and then the Red Sox lost I thought
we weren't gonna talk about this I'm
just trying to say I was told by some of
your friends who want to take you down a
peg that when you go to Red Sox games
they tend to lose is that not the case
yeah it's like every sports game in
general and the new way okay when word
gets out you're not able to get back in
there no my friends actually we're
calling me at points being like hey
you're not going tonight right yeah yeah
yeah this is an important game
you